the haze inequality regions and to
explain to you what these things are you
need to cast your mind back to what we
were just dealing with regular old
single variable inequalities like this I
could say X is greater than or equal to
3 and then I could represent that
visually on the number line if I've got
a single variable X then I just draw a
number line for that variable and I find
the space that represents all of the
solutions for X is greater than or equal
to 3 you can see I've already put all
the most important number one two three
there's the point that's relevant by
boundary and then what am I going to do
in this case yeah so I started coloring
it I'm going to put a put a filled
circle here and then I'm going to take
from this boundary which direction we
get going to the right X is greater than
or equal to 3 which conveniently
conveniently is the third direction this
is all different you whatever so this
blue line with an arrow indicates 80
points on this number line in the blue
area satisfies this is evolving so far
so good
yeah why is there I don't have to hear
should I do
you should have oh just like I mean the
fact that you've got three three needs
three only has beating because zero in
there three means it's three units to
the right of zero and negative 3 we need
three units to the left of zero
everything takes reference from zero
just like what the Cartesian plane which
are good to a shrimp shortly everything
takes reference from the origin like one
one only had meaning because the origin
is there right now as I push down they
just come up as I put it up this is a
single variable inequality a single
barrier
so what would happen if we had worn the
one bear very for example let's do this
so what would this be this is the longer
single variable this is two variables
I guess you sort by variant but that's
usually an additive ways of statistics
if you've got a single variable you just
have a single axis if you have two
variables a single axis is not going to
cut it so we're going to need for two
variables two axes and because we've
chosen x and y we can represent it on
the Cartesian plane so underneath you go
ahead and pop in preventing HIV now what
I want you to notice is this I'm running
out of colors rapidly but we'll do our
best for the inner core the actions
greater than equal to three x equals
three is the boundary value for this
part that I shaded productive x equals
three is the boundary so when you have a
look at this guy here I'm looking for
all of our in Direction Y for which this
statement is true and the pleasure I'm
going to start is it just like x equals
three with the boundary for this y
equals this will be the boundary for my
new two-dimensional inequality
okay now just like with inequalities on
the gum ballon we have something
different for including the battery or
not including the bathroom it's the same
for these guys in two dimensions the
equivalent of a hollow circle is a
dotted line
I don't have to be confusing because we
use dotted lines in choreography of
something else
clearly asymptotes but we run out of
ways so we're also going to use got a
bunch of this so y plus 2x plus 1 looks
something like this I guess and I'm
putting it in dotted daddy I'm putting
it dies because if you have a look here
this tells me that the boundary is not
included and the person to this which
would be solid so they go like on the
boundary now think about this there's an
extra there's a Y so that means you need
an x value and a y value for which this
step it is either true or its false so
for example think of a pair of
coordinates right think of something
like say 3 comma 4 3 comma 4 does this
set of coordinates satisfy the
inequality or not frequent 4 3 comma 4
so remember 3 comma 4 is shorthand for x
equals this and y equals 0
yes so if you have a look at you
substitution in the left hand side
actually 4 is that we come curious
economics you start at the right hand
side first the right hand side is going
to be equal to what it's going to be 2
times 3 plus 1 which is 7 right the left
hand side on the other hand is going to
just need four so you can see in this
case the liquid side is less you
the right hand side do you agree and
that's what I wanted isn't it that's the
direction of the inquiry facing the
creation that's why I started the
gray-head side by the way
so therefore three comma four satisfies
by air quality
so where is very comfortable this is
this is one is it a long ago one two
three one two three somewhere up there
ish okay so three comma four it works
in fact what you'll find is because this
is the battery any point you pick on
this sign of the boundary will also
satisfy these equality isn't other ends
of it easier once you can put in 0 0 the
origin in fact I'm going to encourage
you to choose the origin whenever you
possibly can
0 0 also satisfies these equality can
you see why is 0 less than 1 the answer
is yes so this point also satisfies the
inequality now rather just draw X's and
put tick thanks to them these and I have
an infinite set of points that satisfies
this inequality
just like here I'm going to shade the
appropriate part that includes all of
those points so I'm going to discard
everything on this side you can say to
the right of this line or alternatively
you can say everywhere below this line
this is the region the region consider
two dimensions that represents this
inequality right this is the region that
represents this in the corner which why
we call these inequality regions it's
just like what you're doing on the novel
I accept it in two dimensions rather
than one okay